As software developers we spend most of our time keeping up with our integrated development environment,
So we care about our tools.
I am Reto Mayer. You are viewing Android Tool Time.
This is "Android Studio" version 1.5.
"Android Studio" version 1.5 includes other fixes for errors and improvements.
Which includes an update to the memory analyzer.
This new analytical feature can analyze data to find known problems
Such as leaked activities.
To use this property, open the data window
Find the Task Analysis window on the right.
You can press the Play button in the Analysis window
For analysis.
And then move between the results.
The following is an example of a leak activity.
There are also many ways to check for new links.
Here's one warning
If you try to bypass sources indicated in the statement.
The rest of this looks like bug fixes.
Hide the module selector only with one module in the Appearance Editor.
Correct the address set to create a new module
Using the New Module Wizard.
Provide documentation and completion of XML attribute values.
This can not be true.
Beauty?
Yeah?
Is this true or have I missed something?
Looks just a set of stability improvements
And some bug fixes.
Are generally a set of good fixes for errors.
Well, but as you know
This is my first video in What's New in Android Studio series.
I was hoping to make a big fuss.
I understand this, but these are very important fixes for errors.
I think so.
What about this fund?
Can I tell them what the fund is?
No, we can not talk about the box.
are you sure?
It sounds very exciting.
Look, Reto. Inevitably we can not talk about the fund
Why is it here originally?
We must focus on mistakes inevitably.
Okay.
Well, the Theme Editor has a preview
For the appearance that will be created.
There are a number of bug fixes in the editor area
We were working hard to refine the code completion
For source and statement files.
For example, you can now use short names
When you use the code completion for custom presentations.
We've also noticed that Android Studio has not taken your focus
If you switch between virtual desktops during the start and play phase.
Download Android Studio 1.5 now for bug fixes
Stability improvements and more.
This is Android Studio 1.5.
This is Android Tool Time.
I must completely forget that I mentioned the fund.
What I should have really mentioned.
Stop talking about the box.